- [Narrator] This is a lined seahorse.
A naturally poor swimmer,
the lined seahorse is often found latched
to aquatic vegetation like
seagrass or sargassum.
Rather than hunt,
it camouflages itself and
waits for it's prey to pass.
It's eyes can move
independently of one another
allowing it to scan it's surroundings.
It's habitat is extensive.
It can be found along the
Eastern coast of the Americas,
as north as Nova Scotia,
and as south as Uraguay.
They're quite small reaching only
up to six inches in length.
Because of coastal growth and pollution
the natural habitat of the lined seahorse
has been diminishing.
This, paired with it's common
use in Chinese medicine
and the aquarium trade,
has seen it's numbers
dwindling since the late 1990's.
This is the lined seahorse.